et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
fabien roussel bonjour des bons jeunes
et du nord secrétaire nationale du parti
communiste merci d'être avec nous et
meilleurs voeux et meilleurs voeux
il est encore temps on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
qui dirige le bureau parisien de
ouest-france boulot stéphane bonjour et
blogueuse match on dit par chez moi
on commence par la crise sanitaire
fanhouse est le chef de l'état qui a
priori ne s'exprimera donc pas dans les
prochains jours il préfère attendre de
voir les effets du couvre feu avant de
prendre une décision sur leur
confinement est ce qu il a raison
est-ce qu'on peut encore attendre
écoutez moi je préfère que l'on attende
et que l'on prenne la bonne décision et
que l'on trace une trajectoire pour nos
concitoyens
jusqu'à l'été parce qu'aujourd'hui on
vit dans une période d'incertitude et
l'incertitude s'apaisent pour tout le
monde les jeunes les étudiants les
salariés selon télétravail comme les
chefs d'entreprise il faut être capable
de passer un pacte avec le peuple de
france faut pas avoir peur de lui
il ya pas 66 millions de procureur dans
notre pays il ya 66 millions de
personnes qui souffrent qui ont peur
qu'ils ne savent pas où on va
manuel macron il y as besoin de passer
un pacte avec le peuple de france un
pacte de vérité impact de transparence
qui disent on peut faire on doit passer
par une période de confinement strict
décidons là ensemble trois semaines
quatre semaines et ensuite et ensuite on
des confinera petit à petit on ouvrira
les espaces de culture les lieux de ce
sport parce qu'on en a aussi besoin pour
la tête pour notre santé physique morale
et petit à petit on prendra le temps de
se dé confiné et pendant cette période y
compris pendant la période de
confinement si elle devait arriver ça
doit être une période où on vaccine
massivement nos concitoyens car le
vaccin c'est l'antidote contre ce virus
est ce qui nous permettra de sortir des
périodes de confinement et de couvre-feu
et donc il faut accélérer la période de
vaccination
en gros il faut expliquer aux français
pouvoir dire aux français voilà où
allez dans les cinq mois six mois qui
viennent voilà comment on va s'en sortir
avec les virus mutant s'il faut passer
par une période de confinement allons-y
mais donnons une trajectoire à nos
concitoyens ça pèse sur le moral ça pèse
aussi sur l'activité économique de ne
pas savoir quand nous allons pouvoir ré
ouvrir tous les commerces les lieux de
culture de toutes les activités qui sont
aujourd'hui fermées c'est possible de
fixer une trajectoire a aussi long terme
5 à 6 mois avec une situation aussi
évolutif vous avez parlé de virus mutant
si on dit par exemple on rouvrira les
restaurants et commerces à telle date et
qu'on n'y est pas parce que la situation
sanitaire ne le permet pas ça crée aussi
d'autant plus de déception mais vous
savez je j'ai entendu mois les
restaurateurs les cafetiers de chez moi
ou dans les manifestations je suis allé
pour les soutenir s'il vise pourtant
lisa quitte à ne pas respecter eux ils
disent qu'ils préfèrent lors qu'on leur
annonce qui ne rouvriront pas avant le
mois d'avril par exemple mais que à
cette période toutes les conditions
soient créées pour que l'on ait baissé
le nombre de contaminés par jour que
l'on ait baissé le taux de pression dans
les hôpitaux publics parce qu'il faut
aussi penser à nos hospitalier et à la
surcharge qu'il ya aujourd'hui dans nos
hôpitaux parce que ce gouvernement n'y a
jamais mis décidément les moyens bref il
faut leur donner une trajectoire
ils ont besoin de savoir où on va en
gros il préfère ceux de qu'on leur dise
qu'ils vont encore être fermé pendant
deux mois mais que dans deux mois tout
sera créé pour qu'ils puissent réouvrir
aujourd'hui c'est l'incertitude sur le
flou avec un président de la république
qui vit dans un bunker qui traite les
français comme autant de procureurs
coupé de la réalité coupé du monde et
qui du coup prend des décisions qui
peuvent être aussi coupé de ce que
vivent nos concitoyens d'une manière
générale vous considérez qu'il n'a pas
assez d'informations sûres sur ce qui
est en train de se passer ou ou à l
inverse on l'a trop finalement abaissée
surtout que l'on
ya pas de démocratie et de prise de
décision collective parce que ça fait
bertrand il demande un vrai débat
politique hebdomadaire au parlement mais
vous aussi vous le demander mais tout le
monde le demande
on vient d'avoir encore un débat sur
l'état d'urgence sanitaire de madère 1
to n'y en a pas un débat hebdomadaire
il y a mais vous vous en doutez ce
domaine est une période de tension
permanente difficile nous devons prendre
des décisions difficiles prendra la
décision d'un couvre-feu d'un
confinement avec des virus mutants qui
arrivent avec des taux de contamination
élevée et une situation sanitaire dans
nos hôpitaux compliqué eh bien il faut à
chaque fois pouvoir prendre ses
décisions collectivement aujourd'hui ses
décisions elles sont prises dans un
bunker à 15
enfin au le parlement découvre les
annonces à la télévision le soir la
conférence de presse du premier ministre
ou du président de la république on est
où là c'est une république de bananes
ont crié un débat hebdomadaire pour vous
mais bien sûr et créer les conditions
d'avoir toutes les informations afin de
prendre les décisions collectivement
pour qu'elle soit acceptée est admise
par la grande majorité de nos
concitoyens ils sont prêts à accepter
des conditions
ddd des mesures de confinement si il y a
le muc trajectoire et le bout du tunnel
si on peut leur dire voilà maintenant
que l'on à un vaccin on va vacciner
massivement dont la proximité et crée
les conditions de cette vaccination
j'espère qu'on va en parler parce que
leurs barres dans les manières vrai
scandale et que si cette période de
confinement elle sert à ça a soigné
nausée à vacciner nos aînés à vacciner
les soignants à vacciner tous ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui exposées mais on peut
l'entendre que l'on soit confinée pour
se protéger du virus est en même temps
voir la sortie du tunnel et on parle des
vaccins avec elle alors à propos de
vaccin donc on voit on sait que le
vaccin sanofi sera prêt peut-être à la
fin de l'année on a appris hier que
l'institut pasteur renoncèrent à son
principal projet en la matière comment
et quels regards est ce que ça vous
amène à porter sur l'état de la
recherche française
on est pourquoi est-ce qu'on pourquoi
est ce qu'on arrive
après les autres vous savez je suis
aujourd'hui vraiment scandalisés de ce
qui se passe
moi je veux dire à l'échelle du monde à
cause de laboratoires pharmaceutiques
obnubilé par l'argent qu'ils vont se
faire sur ce vaccin alors que l'humanité
est face à une pandémie un virus qui
mute en plus mais qui est la même souche
le même virus qui circulent sur
l'échelle de la planète et on a des
laboratoires qui se tirent la bourre qui
vont chacun faire leurs recherches dans
leur coin qui vont négocier leurs
contrats avec la commission européenne
ici les états unis là bas ou tel pays
qui décide de payer très cher pour avoir
tout de suite des doses
c'est la loi de l'offre et de la demande
pour obtenir un vaccin
quand toute l'humanité et touchez vous
ne pensez pas que normalement il aurait
fallu que l'ensemble des chercheurs des
laboratoires des scientifiques mettent
en commun leurs connaissances et
qu'ensuite les vaccin trouvé et il y en
à différentes sortes avec des
efficacités différentes mais les
différentes sortes elle ne s'oppose pas
entre le vaccin chimérique d'astrazeneca
le vaccin arn messagers de files heures
ou l'autre celui de sanofi qui
arriverait mais tout s'est tous ces
vaccins devraient être mis à disposition
des pays dans le verset dans le domaine
public sans brevet c'est ce qui a été
fait par jonas salk le découvrir le
découvreur du vaccin de la polio et dès
que ce chercheur américain découvert ce
vaccin de la polio il a fait le choix de
ne pas déposer de brevets et de le
mettre à disposition de tous les pays
pour que les pays le produise rapidement
et pour toute leur population mais enfin
aujourd'hui en afrique en asie en europe
en amérique latine on a besoin
un de ceux vaccins pour vacciner
massivement et donc nous avons la
possibilité nous avons des chaînes de
production des usines est capable de
produire ce vaccin
qu'attend-t-on pour mettre en commun ses
connaissances ses recherches y compris
là les premiers résultats des des
millions de personnes vaccinées sur les
effets indésirables sur le taux de
protection sur le taux de transmission
qui devrait tout de suite mettre ces
chercheurs ensemble pour produire de
nouveaux vaccins améliorée donc
aujourd'hui qu'elle devrait pas scandale
du régime capitaliste mais quelque part
c'est ça parce que ils sont obnubilés
par les bénéfices qu'ils vont faire sur
ce vaccin alors qu'il devrait être
au global et par la vie par la
possibilité de sauver est-ce que c'est
lui ai demandé à fabien roussel oms et
pfizer ont signé un accord ce week-end
pour que les 40 millions de doses de
vaccins de pfizer qui soit
donné en tout cas vendus à prix coûtant
aux pays les plus défavorisés est ce
qu'il n'ya pas quand même une
répartition qui se met en place mais
vous me parlez de quoi vous me parlez de
charité de la part d'un marchand de
tapis pfizer qui annonce à l'union
européenne qu'au lieu de livrer 120
millions de doses
il n'en livreront que 100 parce que dans
les doses on peut on pourrait faire si
ce vaccin au lieu de cinq mois j'ai été
les voir à saint-amand-les-eaux
les médecins qui est justement avec les
infirmières vont essayer d'aller
chercher la 6e doses
il faut en prendre un petit bout d'un
flacon est un petit bout d'un autre
flacon
mais c'est quoi ce bricolage c'est mais
c'est la honte
enfin et en plus ils vont se faire
j'avais gagné beaucoup d'argent je
cotise y vendre 100 millions de doses
quand il en livre 100 au lieu de 120 t
pour le même tarif
on n'a aucune visibilité sur les
contrats qui ont été conclus avec ces
laboratoires
hmm hmm ces contrats sont cachés dans un
bunker de la commission européenne
mais c'est la loi de l'argent qui est en
train de nous pourrir et de tuer la
campagne de vaccination massive que l'on
devrait faire à la place il y un enjeu
fort le président de la raddho la
république si j'étais président de la
république je suis pas peut-être un jour
ça viendra mais on devrait le poids de
la france devrait être de devrait être
mais entièrement à ce pour ce combat
le président la france devrait
aujourd'hui être à la tête d'un combat
pour que le vaccin soit un bien commun
qu'il soit libéré de ses brevets mis à
disposition des pays et que l'on
puissent vacciner nos aînés nos
soignants tous ceux qui sont en première
ligne les les plus jeunes et partout
dans le monde
voilà ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est la recherche du profit
qui les guident protégé par la
commission européenne protégés par des
chefs d'état comme monsieur macron je le
regrette
mourir juste juste je reviens à ma
question est ce que vous n'avez pas
répondu à ma question le fait qu'il ait
pas de vaccin français est-ce que ça
c'est quelque chose qui me pose problème
mais oui ça pose problème parce que
c'est quand même un peu la honte que un
groupe comme sanofi si on peut dire
qu'il ya encore français quand même
qu'un groupe comme sanofi qui est
tellement qui a tellement tapé dans ces
chercheurs dans son dans sa recherche
ils ont supprimer 3000 emplois de
chercheurs en l'espace de dix ans et
sont passés de 6000 à 3000
ils ont supprimé encore 400 là en ce
moment et vous ici mercredi que vous
avez j'y vais justement pour pointer ça
c'est quand même une honte c'est
l'humiliation de la france pas capable
de vacciner pas capable de mettre un
vaccin sur le marché mais à quel niveau
est tombé la nation choix de la france
enfin c'est quand même grave et on a un
groupe guidé par pareille des exigences
de rentabilité et qui a fait le choix de
taper dans la recherche
au lieu d'investir massivement là dedans
sanofi qui a touché qui touche entre 100
et 150 millions d'euros de crédits
d'impôt de l'état pour la recherche le
crédit d'impôt recherche 150 millions
d'euros par an et qui licencient des
chercheurs et qui est incapable de
mettre un vaccin sur le marché la honte
c'est la honte
on va parler des conséquences sociales
de cette crise est d'abord de cette
mesure proposée hier pas stanislas
greenhill déléguée générale de la
république en marche et propose un prêt
à taux zéro de 10000 euros pour les
18-25 ans un capital jeunes pour se
lancer dans la vie c'est ce qui est dit
cette somme serait remboursable sur 30
on est ce que vous soutenez cette mesure
non
la république en marge comme à chaque
fois pense capital pense banques et les
étudiants aujourd'hui d'abord ont déjà
accès à des prêts à taux zéro pour leurs
études
et c'est parce qu'ils demandent d'abord
des prêts à taux zéro qu'ils vont
rembourser en faisant des petits boulots
des jobs précaires les délits verrous et
compagnie alors que
tous ces boulots d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup d'entre eux les restos les
cafés et s'est enfermé ont disparu ce
qu'ils demandent les étudiants
aujourd'hui c'est un revenu minimum
garanti
c'est ce que nous proposons nous à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat les
parlementaires de ma formation politique
nous proposons que chaque étudiant
puisse bénéficier d'un revenu minimum
garanti au niveau du smic
financé par les cotisations sociales que
nous payons tous et qui garantirait à
ses étudiants des conditions d'études
digne leur permettant de ne pas être
obligés de travailler à côté et qui en
même temps engage la société parce que
nous les fines nous finançons leurs
études et nous sommes en droit ensuite
de demander à ses étudiants de
travailler de passer des contrats avec
les tables des fonctions publiques
territoriale ou avec des sociétés du
secteur privé on pourrait dire en
finance vos études et en retour on vous
demande deux ans trois ans de travail
dans tel ou tel secteur ce qui resterait
l'occasion de mettre un pied à l'étrier
c'est ce que nous proposons c'est un
salaire un minimum garanti pour les
étudiants et derrière un contrat garanti
pour leur permettre de mettre un pied
dans l'emploi pour les étudiants pour
tous les plus de 18 ans alors il ya 2
les étudiants qui aujourd'hui souffrent
de la précarité du fait de la situation
que les parties de l'activité économique
est fermé donc il y a besoin d'aider ces
étudiants par un minimum garantie
permettant de poursuivre leurs études et
de l'autre côté il ya ceux qui sont
sortis du cursus scolaire et qui se
retrouvent sans rien qui ont moins de 25
ans qui n'ont pas accès au rsa et qui
n'ont droit à rien
rien ce gouvernement a prévu deux fois
100 100 euros 150 euros depuis un an que
nous vivons la pandémie c'est pas ça
enfin sur le plan de relance il ya 1 %
du plan de relance mise pour lutter
contre la pauvreté
ce n'est pas à la hauteur et donc ces
jeunes qui sont sortis aujourd'hui du
cursus scolaire
il faut au minimum prévoir une aide
sociale mais je suis pas favorable à ça
je préférerais qu'on s'engage alors
poser un emploi une activité on a besoin
d'embaucher pour faire les bataillons
d'hommes et de femmes qui vont à les
accompagner ceux qui sont atteints du
coc vide ou qui sont qu'à contacter il
ya cinquante à soixante mille personnes
à embaucher maintenant allons dit il ya
tellement de jeunes qui demandent
carrément puisque vous parlez d'emploi
et les avais demain à midi ce travail
qui dit ce matin sur rtl que le quoi
qu'il en coûte durera aussi longtemps
que nécessaire à ce que vous dites que
le gouvernement fait ce qu'il faut pour
sauver les emplois pour aider les
salariés pour aider les entreprises
j'ai surtout entendu d'abord un
président de la république qui a dit
quoi qu'il en coûte est aujourd'hui un
gouvernement qui nous dit il faudra
payer
vous voyez entre le quoi qu'il en coûte
et il faudra payer la différence
donc il faudra travailler plus longtemps
c'est fini les aides c'est ce qu'a dit
du soft en disant j'espère que 2021
marche à la crise et donc la fin de quoi
qu'il en coûte ce que nous pouvons dire
c'est qu'entre mars 2020 et décembre
2020 et la période de confinement de
l'année dernière période de pandémie de
l'année dernière les milliardaires du
monde ont gagné 3 1900 milliards d'euros
en plus et lé milliardaire français
bernard arnault madame bettencourt etc
ont regagné eu 175 milliards d'euros de
plus en l'espace de neuf mois
par contre l'ensemble des français eux
c'est la barre d'oxfam ça va prendre dix
ans pour qu'il retrouve le niveau de vie
d'avant eh bien vous voyez cet argent
qui a profité ces bénéfices qu'en
profiter à une infime minorité pourrait
servir aujourd'hui à lutter contre la
pandémie à aider nos étudiants à
financer le vaccin et faire en sorte que
ce vaccin soit disponible pour tous et
rapidement
eh bien non voilà et encore aujourd'hui
les richesses sont captés par une infime
minorité
pendant que nous on nous demande de nous
mettre d'écran à la ceinture la
stratégie qui a été choisi de préserver
l'emploi
quoi qu'il en coûte pour reprendre le
terme c'est une bonne stratégie ou pas
parce que leurs néons refus aussi laissé
filer
comment comme tafer après la crise de
2000 mais tout à fait les entreprises
licencié puis et puis m m 10 ans pour
retrouver le niveau d'emploi
tout à fait mais des jeux et jeux
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises la
politique de chômage partiel et 2009
martial politique est une solution qui
dans l'urgence a permis d'éviter le
chômage et pas dans le nom mais ils ont
le temps l'on sait mais quand vous voyez
que des grands groupes ont profité de ce
dispositif pour mettre des salariés au
chômage au lieu de mettre en place des
plans de formation et de montée en gamme
une partie de leurs salariés dans des
grandes industries je pense à
l'aéronautique
je pense à l'automobile je pense à la
chimie en plus je pense à sanofi mince
alors vous reçoit raymond les avis des
amis au lieu du chômage fort montfort
monte mais mettons profitons de cette
période si on peut dire profité pour
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
salariés de tous secteurs puissent
gagner en compétences et en
qualifications donc l'argent devrait
être plus orienté vers cela mais après
moi je pense aussi à ceux que j'ai
rencontrés dans lors de mon dernier
déplacement en seine-maritime des chefs
d'entreprise des tpe de moins de 10
salariés qui me disent monsieur roussel
nous on n'a aucune visibilité
et là je dois payer 8000 euros
d'assurance pour le premier trimestre
8000 euros d'assurances qu'est ce que
l'on a demandé comme effort aux
assurances rien qu'est ce qu'on a
demandé comme effort aux banques qui
aujourd'hui ne prête pas ou ne prête
qu'aux riches
il faut que l'état soit derrière avec le
pg e pour que les banques acceptent un
canton leur tour un petit peu le bras de
péter de pays de près de prêter aux
petites entreprises
je rencontre des petites entreprises qui
n'ont pas accès aux crédits qui sont
étranglées enfin le poids c'est ce que
nous disons nous communistes le poids du
capital le poids de la finance étrangle
les petits mais par contre est présent
et ouvrant grand ses bras aux grandes
entreprises aux grandes multinationales
cessons cette distorsion c'est cette
différence entre les grosses
multinationales et les petites
entreprises c'est ce qui tue d'emplois
chez nous c'est ce qui tue l'activité
connaît beaucoup de ces petites
entreprises ont des emplois non
délocalisables
et ce sont elles qu'il faut soutenir on
a bien compris nous reste très peu de
temps malheureusement quelques questions
d'actualité ce matin dans le figaro
françois bayrou dit souhaite un
référendum sur la proportionnelle il va
proposer à tous les responsables
politiques intéressés de cosigné une
lettre au président de la république
pour défendre ce changement est ce que
vous signerez cette lettre je les ai pas
vus donc laissez moi ce principe le mont
la proportionnelle nous y sommes
favorables dans certaine mesure c'est à
dire il ne faut pas faire élire des
députés sur des listes nationales qui
serait coupé du sol ça c'est pas notre
choix nous préférons nous de
proportionnelle à l'échelle de
départements de territoire pour que ça
reste dans la proximité et sur une
partie des députés
ensuite ça ne doit pas conduire à
réduire le nombre de députés à
l'assemblée nationale nous sommes les
représentants du peuple et aujourd'hui
avec 577 députés
l'objectif c'est d'être des députés de
proximité donc pas d'être des députés
demain avec des circonscriptions qui
ferait deux fois trois fois la taille de
celles que nous avons aujourd'hui sinon
on sera jamais proche des gens de nos
circonscriptions mais ça doit passer par
un toit y est vous voyez les réserves
que j'y mets mais j'y suis favorable et
ensuite le référendum franchement
franchement c'est pas le sujet c'est pas
le sujet parce que aujourd'hui le sujet
c'est la crise sanitaire c'est l'emploi
c'est les vaccins je suis venu avec des
carambars aujourd'hui aujourd'hui un
petit mot chaud venu avec des carambars
parce qu'en ce moment il ya les salariés
de carambar de marcq en baroeul qui sont
en train de faire grève parce que au nom
d'un déménagement de leur entreprise il
y à un ps 205 salariés aidés et on
demande le fonds d'investissement qui
veut démarche de 20% sur ses actions
leur demande de réduire de 25 % leur
salaire eh bien je suis avec eux et pour
caramba il faut les soutenir parce que
tout le monde connaît carambar
aujourd'hui le message est passé une
dernière question stéphane vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que peut-être si vous
étiez président est ce que le parti
communiste aura un candidat à la
présidentielle en 2022 et bien c'est
toute la réflexion que nous
entamons aujourd'hui nous avons notre
conseil national d'ailleurs ce week-end
qui lance le processus de discussion
pour ma part et avec d'autres de mes
collègues nous circulons aussi dans tout
le pays à la rencontre des salariés du
monde du travail et nous mettons cela en
discussion la discussion que nous
devrons nous ouvrons c est ce que dans
la perspective de 2022
au regard de la crise du capitalisme qui
est aujourd'hui avéré j'ai parlé de la
capacité de ce système économique
d'apporter une réponse avec le vaccin
parce que ils sont obnubilés par
l'argent eh bien nous pensons nous
qu'une candidature communiste a à
l'occasion de ces de ces échéances peut
montrer qu'il ya d'autres choix qui
laissait week il est urgentissime de
reprendre le pouvoir sur l'argent sur la
finance de le mettre au service de tous
qu'il est urgentissime de produire
autrement les richesses
donc vous êtes en commun pour défendre
cette option mais le débat s'ouvre
rapidement fabien roussel en 2017 c'est
grâce au maire communiste que jean luc
mélenchon avait pu être candidat est ce
que là les maires communistes vont lui
accorder leur parrainage
bah écoutez je vous propose de les faire
défiler ici en à 660 cc avaient été
décidés par le par le communiste est ce
que là vous allez décider la même chose
que moi je suis là dessus très clair
chacun fait ce qu'il veut on imagine
chaque élu chaque élu est libre de
donner son insigne mai mais non mais il
y en a jamais vu chaque élu est libre de
donner son parrainage à qui il veut il y
a les 660 maire communiste mère d'une
majorité qui feront leur choix et il y a
les 35000 maires de france à qui je
m'adresserai aussi si le choix était
fait qu'il y ait un candidat etc etc
parce que c'est 35000 maires de france
sont aujourd'hui les sentinelles de la
république ce sont ceux qui tiennent ce
pays aussi à bout de bras et donc ils
sont importants dans cette élection
présidentielle 2017 en 2007 vous aviez
acté au niveau national de votre parti
la stratégie de parrainage là ça sera
pas le cas bah écoutez la ste d'abord on
va faire notre choix de présenter ou pas
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
et ensuite on s'adressera à l'ensemble
des mères si vous n'êtes quand
n'y aura pas de parrainage à jean luc
mélenchon prendront leur décision merci
mon coup fabien au sahel merci d'avoir
été notre invité l'assistance à votre
invitation c'est la pandémie est là une
de réponse face à la pandémie les
frontières se ferment merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous voir on passe au club
des territoires
la mutuelle nationale territoriale la
mutuelle des agents des services publics
locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés
n'aurait transition zéro carbone des
régions vous présente le club des
territoires
[Musique]